now the schedule has been so [ __ ] up
and upside down
Leon Vitaly thank you for coming in was
scheduled for tomorrow but you had it
today so we're happy that you're here
yeah I'm happy to talk to you now how
did you Leo Vitali of course there's a
great documentary on Netflix that's kind
of chronicling everything that you went
through for a lot of years in your life
how did Stanley Kubrick do with
schedules is this guy who you know
spur-of-the-moment you could just throw
something at him okay we're doing this
now or did he go we said we're doing
this at 3:00 no he yeah other way around
I see he used to say okay we're doing
this now and it would be now wouldn't be
like we're gonna do this in three weeks
it's going nope now is the time well you
know he always had a plan laid out but I
mean by the time we reach the end of of
whatever day or whatever production you
realize all that went out the window
depending on what happened on the day
you had planned to do something how many
years did you actually work together 25
Wow and then I still actually work for
him in a way because I do the transfers
over in films you know blu-ray DVDs film
buff I mean honestly I love film so I me
a big Cooper fan yeah you're I'm a big
I've seen uh Carey Linden is my favorite
movie I've seen that twice
alright yeah I was like I mean I was a
good one Jim realizes how foolish talk
about how did you meet Kubrick what was
it was it on the set of Jerry Linden or
was it
but he saw it twice how is that possible
well figure so you were in that movie
yeah and and this was this was after he
had done the Godfather so by then like
yeah it was right it was I mean yeah in
my to my knowledge Francis Ford Coppola
directed The Godfather is that right
yeah the Francis Ford Coppola or Frances
Toyota talking homerun it was one of
those how did you how did you end up
meaning Stanley Cooper yeah okay well I
was told I had to audition for him for
the for the film for Barry Lyndon and I
thought I'm gonna meet him there but it
never happened because he never met
anybody for auditions he just didn't he
was never present and they started I
think it was one of the first times they
did video auditions in the UK I mean
this is way back in the seventies mm-hmm
so I got the part and and I went down to
Salisbury where they were in England
where they were filming and I just felt
this tap of my shoulder and I turned
around and there he was
she said hey Leon I'm Stanley and put
his head out we shook hands and that was
it we were linked how was it being so
close to a guy who is such a mythical
figure like you know I mean this
directors of Scorsese a couple and all
these guys but Kubrick had this his own
kind of world more than Spielberg more
than any of them even other directors
had this mystique that they put on him
he was like unique in that group and
you're you're closest to this person
that everybody wants to be close to yeah
but he always went his his own way I can
tell you whenever we started on a
project we had a script but the third
that we went into the production the
less this grip got done it was a kind of
organic growth so if for instance he did
a scene well I just told you the first
time that I was on set with him he just
said okay I want you to do this scene
the way you think you're gonna do it and
then we'll kind of go from there and
I'll watch you through this little tube
Arriflex tube you connect different
lenses on the end of it
and he take all the crew off the stage
apart from his DOP and you'd have to do
the scene over and over and over again
as he tried to find his first angle you
know and and as we went on he just kept
on saying okay well that's great um try
it a little more like the way you doing
it just then so it was always a case of
drawing something out of you
it was never kind of uh I want you to do
this and I want you to do that you kind
of found your own temperature and
emotional heart of the scene and as soon
as he thought right we've got something
that was his first shot and then after
that every shot in that scene came off
that first shot so he's not a storyboard
ER person I never still rebooted Wow
would you ever see him yell at an actor
no no I mean really
no not really no no no he saved that for
us the first time he yelled at you yeah
yes I do yeah Oh was it for oh no it's
for a total screwup which happened it
was just a miscommunication really about
we were filming Full Metal Jacket and we
were sending these extras to an airbase
where we were filming and there was a
message about somebody who had to be
there but I never caught it but that
didn't really matter to him right but
the thing is you know very often what
she knew was it wasn't personal I know
that sounds crazy but he never sort of
you could stand back and see this is a
venting he's just venting you know and I
just had everything to do with the job
just everything to do with the job and
the fact that it held things up so how
do you go from being an actor in a film
to being his kind of right-hand man I do
you just start throwing ideas at him on
the set and he's like you know I like
you you should stick around
no it was just that we I had 30-day
contract over eight weeks originally and
only had one dialogue see and to kind of
pass by he sees to establish who I was
in film and but I was there so long what
he used to do is get me I had to be
dressed and made up and everything and
sit outside the sand until they wrapped
and then he'd call me in and he just say
okay Leon give me that
dialogue from that one dialogue speech
that I had at the time and so I do it
and he'd say okay thank you very much
good night
shake hands up Irwin and I was doing
this so long and I started to get very
interested in what was going on here the
Builder everything everything are you
looking around you saw this huge bunch
of people and equipment and everything
just coordinating or being and trying to
get to where Stanley wanted it to be for
that shot and it just fascinated me that
so much of so much of the effort was
into the chase of the perfection I guess
I mean it's mostly shade where I can put
it but didn't people just want to please
him people really wanted to please him
oh yeah yeah yes I mean for different
reasons but I would say that that was
the base of it you know but so you start
so you start getting very curious about
everything that's going on exactly
exactly and I sort of said to him I in
the end I was there for seven months and
he'd written in a whole bunch of new
scenes to the end of the movie so
obviously there was already there was
just something about you that he liked
well we had a rapport yeah we sat down
in between breaks we just talked about
anything everything sports movies so
anyway he said well if you're really
interested do something about it
so I did another film it was actually a
Frankenstein film and I said I said okay
I'll do it but I want to work in the
cutting room afterwards Wow
so and I said this is a producer he was
reading this guy and I said oh do free
[Laughter]
sir you did you did this because you
wanted to work with him yeah I wouldn't
get any spares and maybe today we didn't
promise anything but by the way that's
going back to what you said a minute ago
but wanting to please him yeah you know
I mean you wanted to be able to go back
to him and said that thing that you said
I should do yeah yeah yeah and you were
also had it you were in on this de
casting in The Shining as well which was
really interesting where did you go and
what do they have you doing for the
shining he wanted me to find a little
boy Danny so he sent me to Denver
Chicago and Kansas and the reason was
because it was old Midwest so whatever
little boy we found he was gonna have a
pretty new true kind of accent accent
yeah you know and you found him out of
how many kids did you talk to her I had
a four thousand geez you talk to that
many where you saw tape of them or had
no no no no I talked to them then the
ones that would good I taped was there a
fear that you're like I'm gonna pick the
wrong kid I don't know what I'm gonna do
what if he doesn't like it or were you
confident by then that you kind of got
what he wanted well I was confident that
you know I knew what we were looking for
which is it's not describable there were
a set of rules I had to follow you know
one was if they didn't come into the
room with me on their own forget it
and if they were weren't open you know
if they were closed off forget it and
and if their parents wanted to kind of
come into the room with them forget it
right and when I was in Chicago I you
know I met this family and little Danny
LOI who was just for the time and I
broke all those rules now I don't know
why
I wish I knew uh-huh why he didn't walk
into the room with you well he didn't
want to at first
you really didn't he was right this is
frozen stiff you know and he's his mom
and his brother were really nice they
were very sweet but I just got down
there I said you know you come in it's
all right you weren't wearing the dog
suit at the time where you services the
guy in the dog suit blown the other guy
anyway he got in the dog suit probably
thinks he's the next we have Italian I
think family really likes me probably
use me on a bunch of stuff so anyway he
went in with me the end and we just had
about two feet apart and he went silence
again and then he just said gee Leon I
like your suit for some reason and then
we were talking and then he had the most
amazing focus and concentration I've
ever seen kids up to age at nine years
old and none of them had that focus he
had yeah he was wonderful and so I I
started every audition with getting
their own hands and knees improvising
and you know animals and stuff like that
just to get him going slowly introduced
aspects of the scene because you need to
find a kid that's gonna be like adorable
at first but also terrifying in a way
and can turn and can do this sort of
wide variety of emotions that most kids
don't even know what they are yet what
is this whole documentary room 237
whether people are obsessed with The
Shining and all these messy secret
messages secret messages what what does
is there anything to any of that or is
it awkward so one of them is like that
there's Nazi propaganda in it one of
them is that Stanley is is winking at
everybody and letting everybody know
that he filmed the moon landings right
that was one of them a whole bunch of
different possible meanings yeah did you
help him film the film the moon they do
that on his own I think I did
oh I see I see but do you watch
something like room 237 and go this is a
whole bunch of bunk malarkey well yeah
yeah I mean I did well I've actually got
three quite good friends with the guy
who made that but the thing is that
Rodney Rodney yeah yeah yeah he did the
nightmare documentary as well right did
you see that one it's great the
nightmare is about nightmares and bad
dreams and night terrors it's a real
thing
but I think miss Gerri Lyndon over here
Oh Jerry oh man I've seen that twice on
my film buff yeah no I think one of the
things was he wanted people to know how
crazy some of these theories were I know
how many different people saw the film
in different ways in crazy ways but he
didn't really come across like that it
sort of felt like it was a propaganda so
this is what the film really meant and
he says yeah now did to your knowledge
did Stan Lee sneak in hidden meanings
and things like that into his films I
mean cuz it feels when you watch them
like there's this tremendous amount of
detail put into things where it's like
obscure to be in his movie in Stanley
yes like there is enough that you can
analyze and develop conspiracy theories
are there secret meanings behind a lot
of these films The Shining and others no
really I mean you know for the shining
for instance he had me apart from
looking for the little boy he had me I
went around I don't know by the time I
finished about 6070 hotels of all kinds
you know in in all those cities just
taking photographs food lenders and
everywhere bathrooms everywhere every
kind and he had another crew doing it in
three other cities did you guys say the
restaurant think you were crazy when
you're walking with a camera
especially when I found the senator it
and so all of this everything was made
up of thousands of details from all the
research pictures that we all shot so
many of us shot so oh I see so there's
not necessarily one central mind by what
would the hotel of this size happiness
food ladder hotel still there by the way
the one that they use for the Overlook
that is still in Colorado right with the
outside of it yeah yeah inside on the
outside are two different oh right yeah
yeah yeah no they're still there they
used to have a horror film festival
Stanley Park
it's called coincidentally and and they
used to have a Film Festival there every
year which I used to go to but it's got
is a horror film fish big just moved it
so the stuff and I just gonna answer the
stuff in the pantry these are not hidden
messages about the the Indian massacres
you know that's a real bummer I don't
want to think that the conspiracies are
true isn't it fun but it's like that
picture in the games room of this
downhill skier yeah yeah yeah yes and
that woman says it's Satan and it and
behind him is that plume of flame this
you know it's not it's a snow trail well
what about what about one of the
painting and Scatman Crothers house
watching TV over yeah but but there were
hidden no secret meetings but there were
little details in that thing that had to
be intentional like the idea that Jack
is reading Playgirl magazine that can't
be a mistake unless it's a joke or
something no no no those things would
come out when come up when you were
working on the scene for instance you
know we'd say what would Jack Reed look
what did he you know right under guy one
thing and he was an ex-alcoholic well
he's an alcoholic sure and and he had a
very very sort of loose
idea about morality ya know so
those ideas come up I came up at the
time the notes are did you get to know
Nicholson at all did you spend a lot of
time with him it in a way I mean read
because he was on set so much for so
many when we shot for nearly a year
no I mean I told you something you know
you get people like kent nichols didn't
he was the height of his career Ryan
when he's the height of his career Tom
Cruise at the height of his career yeah
these guys you say okay I mean Tom would
have made three movies in the time it
took to make guys my job but all of them
none of those guys Stanley was not
intimidated by any of those guys no but
they all worshipped and I mean that's a
great point they all worsen was the
point that late Tom Cruise for example
you're right could have done a year's
worth of work yeah in the amount of time
it took him to do eyes wide shot
opportunity and when you think it was
probably 20 million a pulp right for
dude right he's not making 60 million
for his wife did you ever see this one
I've never seen like a lot of deleted
are there deleted scenes from The
Shining especially Clockwork Orange I
would love to see anything from that
hasn't been seen have you seen deleted
scenes from that movie
no and in actual fact I went on a
burning mission where he had me take all
those outtakes and burn them but he
didn't want people to see the stuff he
did you watch any other Clockwork Orange
stuff that was blown or deleted yeah
he's probably there for some of it right
no 71 did you you think it was the idea
in the shining was Jack Nicholson's
character did he did he molest his son
do you think we be physically he did it
he admitted it yes in the bar the hotel
where he says he ought to put him away
from spilling all my papers and one
second of too much pressure he injured
him no think he sexually abused him
no I keep trying to get that in there
like you didn't help that's another
theory of the film
I wanted to I wanted to find out no
there was no sexual abuse and I've
always how was the Bhutan full metal
jacket I mean that's it's another
classic it's almost like two movies like
there's yeah part with until gunnery
sergeant Harvard is killed then there's
the second part right over in Vietnam
and people always say the first part
they loved much more than the second
part I love that second part but I think
it's very underrated the second half is
funny because it super swings that way
with whoever you told yeah yeah I mean
and I mean at first when I first saw it
I I was like everybody else and kind of
like that first part but to say I that's
second half of that movie really I'm a
bit of a film buff myself but the second
half of the movie really really has
grown up did you hang out with the guy I
hate my favorite guy in any Kubrick
movie joke no not Lyari no no not the
army or the guy who played them the
Marine Colonel overseas where he goes
well you didn't really hang out because
you never had any time to but you got to
know them because he will you know
so filming so so long so many days on
the scene you know that you got to no
point well where all those guys nice to
you guys that wouldn't talk to other
assistants on a set but because you were
Stan Lee's assistant they probably
treated you a lot better even even
high-profile actors but I treated you
better than they would have the
assistant of anybody else sometimes and
sometimes they do what I was Stanley
spying I thought that would have been a
bit obvious if I was Stan Lee spying we
thought you were Stan Lee spy oh how did
you prove mother you're promoting the
film worker it's just called film
working which is a great documentary on
Netflix yes I saw I loved it thank you
so it's so interesting because you don't
you don't hear a lot about Cooper's
personal life and you don't hear about
the movies and what the movies meant but
you hear about the legend right yeah not
the man not the guy who actually [ __ ]
saw him his shitty cranky moods or to
play chess with him no I didn't know but
I wants to play chess with those people
it was he good yeah yeah that was a riot
it really was because people used to
come in we had a couple
planters who kind of reason we're into
chess and they had their own kind of
chess set so gold embossed and
everything they said he used to come
into the addressee room and they say
right okay later we'll outstanding would
come in to be boo-boo-boo-boo-boo
checkmate and it was like what he was
really a player yeah who is he
intimidated by because everyone was so
intimidated by him everyone worshipped
him who did Stanley look up to him I'm
gonna guess Hitchcock um yeah yeah yeah
I mean he admired other filmmakers of
course Kurosawa Bergman he liked he
liked and he also like you know small
budget stuff where he saw how promising
a filmmaker could be so we'd watch a lot
of first-time director movies you know
and he'd be very encouraging very
Catholic tastes very broad tasty movies
he didn't have a favorite genre or
anything like that
why'd he move to England and stop making
films here oh well he made a positive
glory in Spain then he came to England
made Lolita and he found it was so kind
of conducive because for him because he
was 6,000 miles away from interference
alright you know and so it was a very
kind of a relaxing way of working on his
movies because things are very relaxed
well it probably is now but you know
what I mean that kind of get things done
men of action and all that did you know
did you ever resent him like because you
give up your whole life your whole
acting career and your work he's a
genius and but did you ever have
resentment for it no no no he didn't I
mean if I think about it now I realized
well you know my relationship you know I
didn't see my children in the way that
you know other people see their children
but they came to stay with me vacations
and he used to come to the house when
they were on their school vacations you
know and Stanley would hijack them
they'd go into the kitchen he
he saw the BT yours appeared toast they
say yeah yeah yeah yeah we very mind
this is from when they was seven and
three right up to when he died two hours
later I'd walk into the kitchen with
some information for him and they were
still sitting there just the three of
them it's amazing he's talking so they
had a good relationship as well was
there who were there people
business-wise that were jealous of the
relationship that you had with Stanley
I'm sure especially I mean when you
watch somebody who's great you know I
mean and it's just like in arguably
great right there how would you know
[Laughter]
there's I mean that's an attractive
quality like people want to be around
that people want to be the chosen one I
want him to want to hang out with me I
want him to want me around were there
people that were jealous of the
relationship that you had with him the
way people are love the relationship I
have with Jim Norton yes all right right
they're very jealous it's a dom sub
relationship it's a guy in a suit and a
dog outfit all right it's very much like
doing enjoying the films that each one
of you enjoyed that's right Gary
literally it's almost twice the second
time I had to go to work but I mean I
write all natural lighting by the way
correct yeah he said it was all that
knowing I'm like no because I never seen
the film these hairs taken from this
home were you label jealous of your
relationship okay Stanley
actually said I should you understand
that that would happen and I suppose it
did but you know I never sort of paid
too much attention to it because
sometimes most of the time you know when
there's opposition from other people is
because they're worrying about their
jobs there
the consequences of what you you say
would be for them so any ever saw or
anything like that is a kind of a you
know a push back because I'm screwing up
their schedules like a little bit was
their resentment from people they're
like I just want to talk to Stanley I
gotta go through this guy whoa yeah yes
I would say that happened so people
probably a lot actually times a lot
nicer to you oh oh yeah they want it to
be close to him so I was watching
another great documentary and it's the
one that I believe Stanley Kubrick's
daughter did on the set of The Shining
yeah yeah and him you know brings me
back to you talking about that Stanley
didn't really yell it at actors because
Shelley Duvall right kind of acted like
he was a complete monster on the set of
that film and and I've always wondered
is it because that's who he was or was
he trying to bring out a kind of
psychosis in her for the purpose of the
film well that's much more accurately
thinking about it if you think that you
know by that I'm halfway through the
story Shelley has got to be on such I
can't had to be on such a level you know
for a very long time in that story she's
running around pulling a hair out yeah
being terrified you know what's
happening to that and it's a very high
pitch to get to you know so uh once she
got there yeah that's what she had to
maintain and even take it further and I
gotta say I mean Stanley never sort of
what can I say
so abuse you know you know in that way I
mean what he did was push a pusher
pusher and the way he used to push
everybody well did he film in order to
film like no you know but she she said
and who knows this is her perspective
what to do to get right and that Jack
Nicholson was treated much better than
she was
who's Nicholson was it because he's
Nicholson was it because he's supposed
to be a little bit
[Laughter]
all right but is that the date does that
kind of sum up why the treatment was
different than one way yeah yeah yeah
won the Oscar and one was [ __ ] second
banana I mean I'm personally I think
that she came out of the film you know
and got very little credit for what she
did because she got that page Jack it
would've been as terrifying and
monstrous 100% oh by the way the
clothing in that film her outfits were
so abominable but it was perfect it was
yes yeah and the really good-looking
girl on the tub whatever happened to her
you're talking about the old woman not
the old woman no the one who fits our
tastes yeah which was basically a great
that was a great I probably wasn't meant
to be like a metaphor for being an
alcoholic but you know you start off the
night seeing her this way but did you
get to know her at all the hot lay naked
I probably would you have made it a
point to get to know her Jim yes I
certainly would have right right well
she's the bottle she was yeah she know
maybe I thinking about the one with the
silver hair from Clockwork Orange now
owns a shop of some sort maybe Malcolm
McDowell talked about that where she
owns a little shop in England or she
sells well you think he keeps track of
every person that's ever been in he s he
knows everything about every Stanley
Kubrick movie he's literally the guy
who's in charge to put them on
dvd/blu-ray doing everything how many
times have you seen most of his films
hundreds hundreds more than twice you
never saw any scenes from Clockwork
Orange or any takes like this no still a
picture no in his very first film fear
desire which he hated
why oh he thought it was crap and he
never wanted it to be seen you know so
he actually and that went on for years
and I actually found a copy of it when I
was in the projection booth threading
some film and a projector and I said to
him he realized there's a copy phone
design here and he said to me said Leon
promise me you don't ever look at that
building and I said no I will he said
nope promise me you never look at that
movie so I said ok I promise I won't
look at that movie and I never happened
you still have it
no no that was number one in the olden
century oh wow you know what I would
never have honor that promise you're
maybe try to talk him into releasing it
or something yeah yeah yeah what they
they've done that anyway
Oh was out there they've done that after
he died they put it on how did they get
a copy VD well that was a very good
question because we were looking for the
negative old ears always working for him
and nobody kind of owned up to having it
you know do you they probably your
departed do you have any stuff from
Clockwork Orange
like anything from that that was
ex-wives or whatever anything I guess
when you have that kind of relationship
with Stanley you don't need the props
right well just wanting cuz you happy
because you the archiver too so I mean
I've seen in the documentary or any of
his movies like like all the all ripen
up there of the props no problem no
original scripts or any of that stuff
yeah they said there was a weird moment
in Clockwork Orange to where the guy who
played the governor right ah you know
handed back the scripts and said thank
you at the end and it was like a real it
was really kind of insulting because
nobody handed Kubrick back one of his
scripts if you had one you would keep it
all right all right
oh I see that's interesting yeah yeah
yeah well he might be specifically on
estate which everybody was I mean they
weren't supposed to take scripts I
really didn't know no no no but everyone
did yeah of course wait and he had no
patience for people who [ __ ] up their
lines or didn't know their lines no
you're right he didn't have any patience
for people who see guys I'm sorry I said
did you see guys who were big enough
like you have crews you have Nicholson
and those guys are professional but did
you see guys on that level who he would
tolerate a little bit more from because
of who they were no but I mean I didn't
what what did get misunderstood he
didn't sort of ball people out in the
sand you know what he would do is well
not with the lead actors what'd he do
with them as he always did with
everything was going for a walk with him
and just you know obviously quietly talk
to them and then other people he said to
me to work on the dialogue so that's
what I did with Francis Scatman Crothers
and shiny
was he really screwing things up well he
could say he's dead yeah yeah I mean
he's in his book of Records was growing
up so many lines Oh in that screaming
scene no no the boy oh really how many
takes it was oh I thought it was the
scene I thought it was the scene where
he's zoned where he's like silently
screaming to to Danny I didn't realize
was a dialogue he'd be still dude that
now that was over a hundred tapes so
what did he keep screwing up the lines
or he just wasn't getting yeah you know
he was 68 years old and you know he just
had a problem sometimes you know I kind
of think if I'd be smart I'd have told
him that dialogue in some kind of rhythm
because he could remember every song he
ever saying and so I think it for him it
was just that repetition of not having a
rhythm to sort of hook everything on to
you know and it was a big love monologue
right right well most part of the
monologue was that sorry Sam which was
witty sit with a little boy he says he
says you know so much something happens
to be saved like is someone burnt toast
how is it up to this day
because it was another 40 lights well it
was very good scat but you know Stanley
get mad at him or did he like no I tell
you Stan he was so patient they wanted
the ADEs wanted to say look we should
send him home you know is really he said
no we send him home you'll feel really
bad you understand we sent him home
because of that and so we just
absolutely he was so patient and just
said that's great and further we got on
the more closer he got the closer he got
until suddenly he was there now so but
because it was so difficult will you
guys kind of relieved when he walked in
and took the axe on the chest he's in
the book it's a mallet in the book yeah
jack is chasing with a mallet and their
hedge animals it's not amazing yeah yeah
I thought that the changes did it bother
him that's that Stephen King hated his
version because I thought it was one of
the rare exceptions where the movie was
much scarier than the book I agree and
no he didn't
not one bit yes he didn't care that he
just liked his version at all no Stephen
King's version was [ __ ] I saw it was oh
they did heavy well it was awful have
you seen the the Stephen King version of
the show part 1 of it that was enough oh
here's a question I did any like there's
one of the very few Kubrick mistakes but
there is one in the opening of The
Shining the [ __ ] out of here yes I swear
to God how do you know it was one it's
only one I've ever caught very rarely
have caught his and he's seen all the
movies at least 2 times absolutely the
wakening awesome film
nurse Strangelove is the opening that
they're going into the noun that that
amazing music yeah that that horrifying
opening music yeah there's a moment
where you see the shadow of the
helicopter
flying over the mountain and I'm like
that must have driven him nuts if he saw
that well you could be surprised when
you hear this you know he was also a fan
of people like playwrights like Burt
Obrecht
I don't know if you know anything I do
believe you do Yeah right right
could you explain cuz i'm lost hes on
board I I'm I'm very stupid well Breck
had this idea which you used the usual
time it was called alienation where he
wanted people to understand from time to
time that they were actually in the
theater and they were watching you know
a play you know so he taped them out of
the situation but I'm not saying they
planned with a helicopter not a mistake
you [ __ ] no well he was for them you did
it sure but for Stanley it was so what
you know I mean so he was still wrong
Jim was still wrong like Dr Stanley
crazy you were even I would have thought
that it did but not it didn't I when I
left my Cooper shots the most is the
long that the long hallway shots which
are like them there so yeah it just fell
off and when I got to its parent
earthquake we're out here I'm frightened
it was the long like petite like when
Danny turns around and he sees the two
girls or the Clockwork Orange zoom in
like yeah is that all his director of
photography or was that his vision first
no no no nothing happened he did you
find a little girls were you the one who
did yeah
I was desperate because I'd found one
good little actress for one of the great
egos and in the book but you know any
good you know bus children with schools
where they have to like a Nickelodeon
actor yeah yeah today but on the very
last day the rayless
panda came in with those girls and I
just looked at them I thought oh my god
they look they like the twins in that
time
Hoppus you know she got a famous
photographs of those two twins
there's twins standing in in Central
Park looking really kind of weird and I
just thought oh my god this is great
so I videoed them very quickly and I
just ran on the set to Stanley said yeah
I've got him I've got him I've got him
and we looked at the video and first
thing he said was you reused today we
use a lot of people cuz I know the
father who played Delbert Grady played
the father in a Clockwork Orange I used
a few people right if he could use
anybody not just actors but anybody and
the technical side to work with again
you know who enjoyed working with sure
we you know if the there was a role for
them then sure welcome and when he was
done with you Malcolm McDowell we had
him on few years ago and he said that he
was really hurt that he wanted to
maintain this relationship with Kubrick
and a lot of people just wanted to be
close to him but when the movie was over
it was like [ __ ] adios yeah did you
ever worry like oh I hope that I'm
maintaining our relationship maybe early
on Co we're six months in oh I don't
know if he likes me I hope he wants to
keep doing this I kind of want to keep
doing this for a while what it was funny
because when we were actually gonna
shoot him Barry Lyndon and he's Harry
what it was Barry
but he said Leon broken he said Leona
would hold on because I want to talk to
you and I thought oh my god that's me
gone because we had three George the
Third's ironically what are you firing
him yeah yeah and I thought that was it
for me but it wasn't it was exact
opposite but um you know it was one of
those things where I don't know how to
put it because we kept in contact even
after the production you know
and he'd send little Christmas gifts and
you know to be in my wife and you know
so we were always in contact with each
other do you think anything Eyes Wide
Shut is an underrated movie yes yeah cuz
I mean I just you're in it by the way
you did I just I mean I just adore that
movie and I feel like people do not talk
about it when they talk about Kubrick's
work but I just think it's a great thing
Barry Lyndon
yeah he got trashed when it first came
out and I went to New York with the film
worker you know for a festival there and
there were all these film students 18 19
20 years old and they'd come out to meet
it oh my god would you seen Eyes Wide
Shut is my favorite movie I love it it's
fantastic and a lot of people are coming
back to me saying well you know I didn't
get it at first but now I've got to see
it again you know I realized it it's
really and so it's growing just like
Barry Lyndon did Barry Lyndon didn't
really blossom until the I'd say middle
nineties when all of a sudden we were
getting feedback back from people saying
they just seen it again and they hadn't
understood it and you gotta remember
that Barry Lyndon you know was released
at a time when you know Dog Day
Afternoon you know try that oh these hi
what for the super special flu of the
cook that was a period that came out and
where nobody moved faster than one mile
an hour right walk it you know it wasn't
exactly an action oh right I don't you
know say that same thing first happened
with Barrie Lynch I wasn't the one oh
she doesn't want yes yes yes it was only
the sort of the kind of younger ones
that carried it through and we had Demi
had a comparison board with the critics
who said something about distant in the
beginning and what they said about it up
to a year later which movie do you mean
2001 what's that that's but anyway so
and it was soon it was
so black-and-white it was so negative
negative and then suddenly they realized
what a masterpiece it was so he didn't
like it but you kind of used to that
kind of reaction to his movies it's also
too like when you look at like Nicole
Kidman that scene she has with Tom
Cruise where she's talking about wanting
to [ __ ] that sailor I think it's the
best moment she's ever had on film was
that where she's telling him she would
have thrown the whole thing out yes to
have one night was because you were
fully erect while you were watching I
certainly was yes a British lady talking
about [ __ ] somebody yes I did like
the British Australian part the scene
had the problem I was so focused on the
erection when when Stanley was towards
the end of his life co-directing Stanley
Kubrick yeah
which towards the end of his life in
directing film was there any sort of you
know this isn't the same Stanley he's
kind of losing it like this is the end
or is his mind still sharp and firing as
much as it was still firing I mean it
was no he was very very tired Oh Grod
Grundy that I mean he was very tired
physically tired but we were working
like 80 70 days a week you know and he
was 70 so you know you do get tired
easier but you know he's pushing himself
through it and but his mind was as sharp
as it has to be so frustrating when you
have a mind that sharpen your body is
just not catching up with yes right yeah
you don't have either Jim audition where
hope we get the gig so now white shirt
how long much filming was done after he
died and were there parts of it that
were in the final production that were
not put together the way he would have
wanted it no no he he died she sent a
final cut to New York the Terry Semel
and Bob daily they're the heads of water
brothers and Tom and Nicole to see that
was a week before he died and that was
his final cut to nothing and you
maintain that he had final cut
directors that could died think their
God final Kyle absolutely but you know
we had a problem with with the centers
and they say there's no senses but there
are sensors believe me because then that
masked ball seen where you know he
touring around the algae was depravity
going all around him they wanted to make
cuts in that and we just refused to do
it he said no no no he but we argued it
we argued it and they kept on saying
well he's gonna get an X rating and
that'll harm the audience attendance you
know and so in the end they came up with
that compromise about putting CGI
figures sort of in the ways in the way
hardly obscured you know which was but
anyway I'm it doesn't you don't have to
do that anymore no right you'll see it
the way it was shot right and the only
thing we had to do was to lay in the
sounds say only thing we had to do but
the soundtrack to build up the final mix
which was very good so now is a
reversion without those things in the
way yeah yeah you know video but he did
have like contractually they couldn't
take any change anything once he handed
in it I never read a contract of his
which were gen me that Nick threw one
out the table once that's my contract
you want to read it no thanks but you
know he was respected too much yeah and
they knew whatever it said in the
contract you know you know if anybody
argued to do it they were gonna get a
face full of crap
is that is that letter of myth too or
he'd they were gonna do a sequel what
movie were they talking about doing a
sequel to and he went crazy
Jerry London no that was a film part
three with Richard Pryor and Krista
other super and three yes we gonna do
2010 and he wrote something and he went
he went nuts yeah he's that letter of
fake where he said somebody died yeah I
know what he said he still got the jewel
bone skeleton you shove it so far up
their ass you know I don't know I wasn't
around at the times
I can't see but it's not really the way
he ever kind of approached a letter or
there's nobody do you remember the most
pissed off he ever got what you meet
person you saw that I saw with you
personally I think the most pissed off I
ever ever saw him was when somebody
suggested to him that he'd get himself a
proper professional editor he just went
off he came into my office I thought it
was me done something you know he just
came into my office and he picked up my
phone clear this table like God have all
these six months of colita de
Correspondence about transfers and [ __ ]
that we were doing you know and he was
beating the walls with his fists and he
was just so angry and he just felt so
what can I say insulted absolutely who
suggested yeah did that person ever know
the how angry he did did you say
anything to Stanley like when he was
doing that breaking things like well
you're cleaning it up Stanley don't
break my [ __ ] nobody took me took me it
took me like two three days to get all
those hundreds of communications with
him Jerry did you ever yell at him we
had arguments yeah did you ever win any
I actually got an apology from him once
whoa for what for what because I gave
him some information and he was in the
middle of you know he was editing or
what-have-you
rang me up and said you know there's a
lot of time [ __ ] Leon every time and
then somebody else had rung him after he
told me that and giving him the same
information that she told him it was
about how many boxes of the Prince the
Prince could you get inside an aeroplane
you know and because we were flying
these out to France and we were all on
deadline you know and he rang me up and
he said I'm sorry Leon
I'm sorry Leon I'm sorry Leon you were
right
Wow there you go that has to feel great
when he did I mean when he passed away
yeah was there this moment for you where
you're like well what the [ __ ] do I do
now I've I've dedicated my life to this
man's work right called Judd Apatow hey
[Laughter]
movies remind me of Stanley well we were
still in the middle of so just back to
work finishing yeah yeah yeah and that
was an amazing thing
and you know I don't think I felt it he
died in March and I finally kicked the
last print of Full Metal Jacket out I've
made eyes might shout out to the
Veloster Ettore which was Turkey
actually and it was in the end of August
and that was when I sort of kind of
thought oh my god he's kind of gone you
know because all the time you carried
this thing around with him still do to
this day where if I drops up you'll do
something dumb I go oh Emily what are
you doing
just the way you used to talk you know
and but then you know they wanted me to
carry on and work with the all the
restorations for is a camera negatives
of the sound of what have you net was
the DVD collection to came out that took
like three years and then we went on
deep blu-rays and then we went on other
stuff what do you have a most of all the
things that you have from him with a
little notes or whatever is there
anything you have that you treasure the
most that you got from him um yes he
there was a note he left me which was
about something he wanted me to do it
was about do some research into cameras
and what-have-you and it was quite so
short and then there was this sort of
splodge at the bottom of the note and he
circled it and wrote by the way this is
coffee stain it is not mice not Batali
the the documentary is on Netflix I
suggest everybody goes so good call film
warriors yeah I want to give a shout
Tony
Sierra who directed it you'd made it
shot it yeah and there's but your feet
have produced there was just two people
he spent three years filming and he had
I don't know 200 hours of material Wow
and he got it it was like a jigsaw and
he got it down to what it is now it's
very good and I'm so glad there are
people like you and him that are that
are still talking about Kubrick and
telling the stories and getting the
films out the way they're supposed to be
out he's just I mean he's still has the
unmatched brilliance of this guy yeah
it's still just incredible I know and I
can't tell you it's amazing how many
people actually say how much they love
his films and they loved him for his
vote well yeah if you bump into somebody
if they know who you are if you met you
spielberger Coppola or any of these guys
they all want to talk to you because you
were so close to him no really do well
sure Arthur no